ne le cherchez pas il n'est pas
référencée dans ce rayon de fournitures
scolaires
pourtant le masque fait bien partie des
incontournables de la rentrée
obligatoire au collège et au lycée
il reste à la charge des familles ça
devrait être pris en charge par l'état
voilà parce que c'est un gros budget
pour certaines familles donc je pense
réellement que c'est une responsabilité
de chacun quand il ya des maladies de la
grippe
l'état peut pas tout financer les
masques ne seront pas fournis par les
établissements scolaires le premier
ministre jean castex
on a fait l'annoncé ce matin sur france
inter le masque à l'école c'est pas une
fourniture scolaire c'est un outil de
protection comme tous les citoyennes
dans la société
voilà donc c'est pour ça que je renvoie
une question de principe c'est au chacun
doit apporter son écot pas de gratuité
générale du mas pas plus qu'il en existe
ailleurs en psy bhl les vulnérables à la
maladie et les plus précaires
pour les associations de parents
d'élèves on comprend la position du
gouvernement
mais on pointe le risque d'inégalité
sociale notre crainte c'est que pour ces
familles à bas revenus
elle se dirige vers l'achat de masques
qui ne serait pas conforme
de son côté le collège de saint vith a
déjà anticipé la rentrée l'établissement
s'est constitué un stock de masques en
tissu et jetable pour prévenir tout
oubli passagers d'un élève
l'élève sera accueilli par un
surveillant qui va immédiatement lui
fournir un masque
il n'est pas question que l'élève reste
à la porte de l'établissement et nous
prévoyons même aussi de donner la petite
pochette en plastique pour les élèves
pour mettre leurs sacs leur masque
usagers en cas d'oubli
en franche comté le territoire de
belfort et la haute saône ont annoncé
donner un masque à chaque élève
le jour de la rentrée